bonjour et mad men à merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france ce matin au liban
les manifestations ont repris on le sait
depuis plusieurs jours mais est-ce qu'il
ya eu cette nuit de nouvelles
protestations
toutes les nuits il ya des protestations
qui sont organisés de manière très
naturelle dans plusieurs régions du
liban surtout dans les régions les plus
défavorisées
c'est un tout petit peu la différence
avec les manifestations d'octobre et de
novembre 2019 qui à la base regrouper
des gens de toutes les catégories
sociales surtout dans les centres des
grandes villes
mais depuis quelques jours les
manifestations ont des revendications
sociales et économiques beaucoup plus
forte
elles sont beaucoup moins organisés et
elles sont éparpillées dans les régions
les moins favorisés du pays et justement
est-ce que l'annoncé de ce plan de
relance économique et une possible aide
financière du fmi
est-ce que cela ça peut calmer la rue ça
va difficilement calmer la rue parce que
le plan de relance comporte également
des mesures bancaires et fiscales qui
sont vraiment difficile et lourde à
porter je pense qu'en général les
libanais les manifestants mais la
population en général est prêt à faire
des sacrifices c'est vrai que la
situation est particulièrement difficile
au niveau de l'inflation au niveau de la
pauvreté et du chômage
le problème c'est le manque de
crédibilité des partis au pouvoir et de
l'opposition où la demande des deux os
famille et toutes les hypothèses que le
gouvernement a émises afin de relancer
l'économie sont toutes basées sur une
série de réformes essentielles de
mesures de lutte contre la corruption de
restauration de la confiance de
restauration des fonds qui ont été
spoliés par les différents partis
politiques au pouvoir et ce sont ces
mêmes partis qui sont censés adopter ce
plan au parlement et il ya ici une sorte
de contradiction qui fait que les
libanais abstraction faite des mesures
écrite dans le texte ne crois pas que
cette classe politique est capable et à
la volonté de mettre en oeuvre
effectivement ces mesures alors
on parle de mesures je cite
indispensable pour avoir cette aide
internationale c'est à paris qui demande
cela à beyrouth d'impliquer donc ces
mesures indispensables
concrètement en quoi la france peut
aider le liban dont son plan de relance
on sait qu'il ya des liens étroits entre
la france et le liban depuis un certain
temps la france a depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années accompagné le liban
dans à chaque fois que le pays
traversait une grave crise économique
ça a commencé même en 2001 et 2002 lors
de la présidence de jacques chirac avec
les conférences qui à l'époque ont pris
le titre de paris 1 paris ii et puis il
ya eu paris iii quelques années plus
tard et enfin la conférence être en
avril 2018 sous la présidence de
d'emmanuel macron à chaque fois la
france
regrouper les différentes puissances
internationales les grands fonds et les
grandes banques internationales pour
soutenir le liban soit à travers un
soutien au budget de l'état libanais
soit à travers des débris garanties à
des taux d'intérêt particulièrement bas
et à des échéances longues et
dernièrement un grand plan de soutien
aux infrastructures libanaises un grand
prendre de soutien à l'investissement
public
or à chaque fois le liban prométhée aux
bailleurs de fonds que la france invité
des mesures effectives au niveau de la
corruption de la bonne gouvernance et de
la transparence et sans aucune exception
le liban a toujours échoué à mettre en
oeuvre ces plans les partis politiques
n'ont jamais voulu lutter contre la
corruption qui est leur oxygène les
partis politiques commettrait un souci
données est ce que là ils vont vouloir
ils n'ont plus la possibilité de le
refuser aujourd'hui le liban est un
niveau très proche de celui du venezuela
au niveau de la structure économique
général les pertes cumulées du secteur
bancaire de la banque centrale dépasse
de loin le pib du pays sont autour de
200% du pib
si rien n'est fait c'est un effondrement
total et on parle d'une inflation qui
sera sans aucune limite d'une
dégradation du taux de change de la
livre libanaise sans aucune limite et
sans aucun précédent dans l'histoire
et je ne parle pas uniquement de
l'histoire du liban on dépassera la
situation du venezuela
donc c'est une question essentielle
s'ils veulent garder un minimum de
relations normales avec les citoyens
sinon le pays se dirigera vers une crise
politique sécuritaire et économique qui
dépasse tout ce que nous avons connu
jusqu'à présent on sait que ce plan de
relance a été largement critiquée par
les banques libanaises ce que les
difficultés avec les banques locales
peuvent être un obstacle aux discussions
avec le fmi puisque les banques sont
aujourd'hui les premières créancières de
l'état libanais absolument les banques
sont très puissantes elles ont également
une forte de représentation politique
le gros problème actuellement au liban
c'est qu'il ya cette dichotomie entre la
position des banques et la position de
l'état l'état qui dit les banques ont
tellement profité des taux d'intérêt
payés par rapport à la dette libanaise
donc maintenant ce sont aux banques de
supporter le poids de la crise alors que
les banques disent c'est l'état qui a
été tellement mal gérée qui a qui a
laissé son déficit et sa dette
s'accumule et qui est responsable et
c'est la corruption qui doit être arrêté
d'abord avant de demander quoi que ce
soit aux banques
le problème c'est que les deux camps se
sont entraidés se sont mutuellement
donner des services tout au long de ces
30 dernières années
donc au lieu de s'inscrire dans une
forme de dichotomie pro banque ou pro
état il faut d'abord ajouté un plan ou
bien une idée essentielle un concept qui
manque au plan de l'état qui est celui
de la redevabilité de la carte belletti
le gros problème du plan qui a été
présenté le en termes de manque c'est
qu'à aucun moment où on voit clairement
les mesures de judiciaires qui sont
nécessaires pour effectivement punir
tous les responsables aussi bien
politiques gouvernementaux que bancaires
qui ont laissé les chiffres explosent et
et atteindre leur niveau actuellement je
pense que c'est ce point là qui doit
être la demande essentielle des citoyens
libanais mais également de nos
partenaires internationaux sans
transparence sans justice sans que ceux
qui ont été responsables de cette
gestion calamiteuse des finances
publiques mais également des politiques
bancaires ne soient vraiment puni pour
ce qu'ils ont fait
le plan restera difficilement applicable
étant donné que chacun des deux camps
les banques d'un côté et le gouvernement
de l'autre vont toujours se renvoyer la
balle
et personne ne pourra effectivement
mettre en mesure mettre en oeuvre les
mesures qui ont été listées dans ce plan
merci à humaine
menad avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
exécutif de la fondation samir kassir du
nom du journaliste et écrivain assassiné
à beyrouth en 2005